it's satellites that can be as small as
a shoe box that are giving us a view of
a conflict zone we've never had before
these are nano satellites being
assembled in glasgow and soon to join a
constellation of more than 100 already
in orbit listening in to signals from
ships and aircraft they spotted the
russian navy and the black sea switch
off tracking beacons just before the
invasion so by shrinking satellites down
and miniaturizing the technologies of
these small satellites are more capable
you can deploy them more cost
effectively but what you can also do is
deploy many more of them
slightly larger commercial satellites
are providing the crisp images of
convoys damaged airfields and bombed
buildings their cameras are so good they
can spot objects just 30 centimeters
across even catching a missile being
launched and with so many satellites in
orbit it's possible to monitor the same
area several times a day
the military has had access to that kind
of detail for many years but the ukraine
conflict has launched it into the public
domain open source intelligence from
small satellites is giving us an
independent eye on what's going on and
then once you have training data even an
ageing satellite owned by the european
space agency can lead to surprising
discoveries this general purple
background is what we would expect to
get back from the satellite these
lighter blue
splotches are
something on the ground a military radar
most likely causing interference
it's a training exercise in belarus just
before the invasion and the scientist
has now written radar detection software
so anyone can search images from the
sentinel satellite in the conflicts that
i've lived through you know the invasion
of iraq and and all of that the only
imagery that came out of it were the
images that were being released by the
us department of defense
and and you just kind of had to take
their word for it you know
now anyone with an internet connection
can check for themselves but even if
governments can no longer control what
we see the images can still be used to
shape public perception from a
propaganda point of view
nato could use this in terms of say this
is what the russians are doing
specifically to
prove that the russians are not telling
the truth about this conflict by being
able to use uh public available images
uh they can turn around and say hey this
is this is uh this is what's happening
you can see it for yourself two
one
but satellites are giving us eyes and
ears on parts of ukraine beyond the
reach of tv cameras and civilians with
mobile phones the horror of war is being
seen from above
thomas more sky news glasgow